oh
bienvenue donc à la plaine des palmistes
vous êtes donc à 1200 mètres d'altitude
dans mon champ de tes données suivez moi
je vous présentais
[Musique]
je suis si lui et à kawa donc
l'entreprise s'appelle botanica casa t
parce que ce sera spécifique dans le thé
et la transformation alors mon cursus
d'avant c'était surtout dans la
pharmacopée toujours dans la
transformation des produits injectables
et donc ça a duré quand même une
vingtaine d'années et après ça donc je
me suis orientée mais la phytothérapie
ce qui m'a amené aujourd'hui vers ce qui
aimait la nature et retravaillé la board
culture qui une formation que j'avais
depuis quelques années sur la réunion je
suis aujourd'hui donc accompagné par
certipaq qui va me permettre de
labelliser les parcelles de fruits de
thés en bio ce qui est très important
donc pour mon avenir
c'est un projet donc de transformation
de produits plus exactement les fruits
de la réunion comme le jeanne rose
athlètes chi l'ha papa mêmes parce que
pour faire un mélange avec le thé que je
vais aussi transformé et je me dois donc
d'avoir d'autres matières premières pour
apporter le côté gourmand le côté fruité
autrement sinon je fais que du thé vert
puisque il ya une base aussi du thé vert
qui est très intéressant et très
enrichissante je transforme donc s'est
produit dans un laboratoire je suis en
partenariat avec le laboratoire pour
pouvoir faire la déshydratation de ce
produit au qui garde la vie de ceux des
fruits et ainsi que les saveurs et dans
l'avenir on va aussi travailler sur de
la cosmétologie sur le thé vert et le
goyavier parce qu'il ya 10 36 occident a
des qualités appropriées pour faire
l'hydratation de la peau et ça donc
c'est avec technopole que je le
travaille et j'ai fait l'acquisition des
parcelles dont avec la safer
même si j'en avais déjà auparavant j'ai
découvert qu'ils avaient du thé et à
partir de là c'était une victoire pour
moi parce que ce qui existe depuis 1749
sur l'île de la réunion de dimanche
c'était la campagne des jeunes qui les
avaient emmenés et c'est bénéfique
pouvoir le mettre en avant et le faire
connaître davantage donc il ya des
techniques bien spécifique j'ai commencé
avec le tube c'est des méthodes de
de cuisson pour pouvoir faire sortir les
enzymes on va chauffer donc le tn
certaine température le faire suer et
ensuite après on va commencer à les
faire sécher sur des greens tout ça pour
tenir un thé vert spécifique
hippocrate a dit que la santé commence
dans l'assiette et je dirais dans nos
passes